con barricadas policiales la policía
turca dividido la manifestación de este
8 de marzo el Día Internacional de la
mujer en Estambul ahí era una parte de
mucha gente que no se le permite entrar
donde estamos ahora que es donde está la
mayoría de la gente sin embargo estas
personas aquí no querrían estar en ese
sitio sino que querían estar en la
famosa calleciclal la más concluida en
Estambul sin embargo desde hace muchos
años que la policía turca las
autoridades turcas prohíben esta
manifestación por el 8 de marzo y no
permiten que las mujeres marchan para
protestar por sus derechos muchas de
ellas hoy mismo están aquí cantando no
solo
quedamos y gritos feministas sino que
también cantan y stefaques a traducirse
el español es gobierno de Misión una
petición muy normal En todo en todo el
mundo sin embargo que ahora mismo se ha
vuelto mucho más política en Turquía por
el hecho de que el gobierno está
luchando contra todos los que lo hagan y
todos los que lo griten incluso han
tenido varias personas en otras
manifestaciones para hacerlo aquí de
momento se está permitiendo queremos más
libertad para toda la gente acá para las
minorías para las mujeres porque no
podemos vivir más acá no podemos tenemos
que tenemos que liberarnos acá hay la
policía los amigas los amigas no pueden
venir acá necesitamos que toda la gente
sea con nosotros y tenemos que ser todos
así sino no podemos vencer este gobierno
porque no podemos Pues eso como lo oyen
las turcas no se les permite que
protesten juntas no es la primera vez
que ocurren muchos otros manifestaciones
también el día del orgullo que hay la
policía lo bloquea y hoy mismo también
está ocurriendo lo mismo en el centro de